hey guys welcome back to dlm men's
lifestyle my name is Daniel just in case
you're new here and in this video I'm
going to give you my top 10 cologne
choices for men
let's not waste any more time let's get
to it
all right guys number one on my list and
I'm not sure if this is how you
pronounce it if anybody is getting angry
about these things I am sorry well not
really this is just how I pronounce it
Hermes from Hermes
okay that's just me on purpose trying to
pronounce it really strange but it was
launched in 2006 but it is still great
it gives you a woody fresh warm spicy
and earthy smell the top notes are
orange and grapefruit model notes are
pepper flint and pellargonium and the
base notes are Cedar vetiver bakulian
benzoin now I know it was launched back
in 2006 but it is still a great cologne
the reviews everywhere you look are off
the charts I mean people like this I
just think that I could have designed
the bottle just a little bit better but
that's just my personal choice it is a
great cologne try it out for yourself
[Music]
Versace Eros it just sounds great and it
smells the way it sounds Euros meaning
romantic love and Greek this is a great
cologne I like it it might be a bit too
sweet for some men but give it a smell
whenever you're near a shop and try it
out give a little bit to your wife and
ask her what she says the main notes are
ambroxon Cedarwood uranium green apple
and lemon
Creed aventis you probably already heard
about this by now because a lot of
people are talking about this it is a
great cologne but it's not always a good
thing if something is popular because
that means a lot of people will already
smell like it so you don't want to be
just another guy smelling like this it
probably depends on the type of people
you hang around with in the circles so
if not a lot of people you know where's
this cologne then go for it you will
smell ambergris Bergamot musk Patchouli
and pineapple
the next one is Dior Sava Elixir this is
a special cologne I actually have it
right here now I am not one of those
guys who go out and just buy 10 colognes
and keep all of them and no first of all
I don't have that much money and I just
buy cologne whenever I need it this time
I chose Sava man this just smells great
it is a classic it will probably never
go out of style and uh you can
definitely give it a shot top notes are
cinnamon nutmeg grapefruit and cardamom
in the middle note is lavender and the
base notes are Amber Sandalwood
Patchouli and vetiver
[Applause]
dual home intense from Christian Dior
now it is really intense it smells great
the top note is lavender middle is
amberit pure and Iris the base notes are
vetiver and Virginia Cedar now this
cologne is sharp sweet and warm kind of
if I can explain it in that way some
people might think it's a little bit too
sweet but check it out for yourself
Club the nude intense from armoff their
reviews are through the roof people like
this cologne a lot for example on
fragrantica it scores 4.24 out of 5 with
9400 votes the main smells you get from
high to low fruity Citrus leather Smoky
woody aromatic fresh and musky the only
negative thing about this one is a lot
of people don't like the the strong
lemony smell that it gives off but if
that's your thing try it out
[Music]
Hugo Boss UD saffron now I always liked
Hugo Boss I mean the name just sounds
Hugo Boss their colognes were just so so
but this one
is different this one is special you
smell the notes of saffron argarwood
labdenum and rose it's got a strong warm
spicy Woody smell very manly and I like
it
Abercrombie and Fitch away now this one
I love the bottle it looks really cool
and it and it smells the way it looks it
almost looks like it feels like a a
holiday if that makes sense in any way a
tropical beach kind of vibe it gives you
a woody aromatic kind of smell and it
was launched back in 2021 the top notes
are grapefruit pineapple and violet the
middle notes are ginger uranium and
pepper and then the base notes
Sandalwood Woody notes and vetiver give
it a try it's fresh uplifting and long
lasting
Versace Dylan blue this bottle just
looks classy and it smells that way as
well it was created by Alberto Morelos
with the top notes of calabrian Bergamot
water notes grapefruit and Figley the
metal notes are ambroxan black pepper
Patchouli Violet leaf and Papyrus base
notes are incense musk tonka bean and
saffron if you've never smelled this one
remember next time when you go to a
store just go in and smell it oh and
remember all the links of all the
cologne I'll add that for you in the
video description down below so it's
just easier for you to go check it out
and maybe order online
[Music]
all right guys we're at the last one and
this is actually one of my top three
this is this is a cologne that I really
love that I will probably use until the
day I die
it is Vince Camuto Terra
it smells good it smells manly and it
just well I don't have any words to
explain to you how much I like this it
gives you a beautiful mix of citrus
granium rhubarb sandalwood and tonka
bean notes it's a strong warm Smoky
mysterious smell and that's why I like
this now if you don't know how to use
cologne effectively how many times to
spray it where to spray it check out
this video here and it'll definitely
help you out and before you go always
remember life is short so don't waste
yours cheers guys